the biden administration's first
high-level talks with china publicly
exposed the tensions between washington
and beijing
china's top diplomat lectured u.s
administration officials for 15
minutes about alleged american
shortcomings
actor after secretary of state tony
blinken criticized china this all
happened
in front of cameras and reporters senior
foreign affairs correspondent and face
the nation
moderator margaret brennan joins us
margaret good morning
these were some pretty tense exchanges
we're talking about here
what do you think we should take away
from this
anthony this is what is now called wolf
warrior diplomacy that's the newly
assertive approach that the chinese
leader xi jinping has adopted
these high-level meetings are usually
really scripted you get about two
minutes to air your grievances at the
top
and you do it in sort of a hedged polite
way but this
top chinese diplomat just blasted the
u.s as you said for 15 minutes
a litany of complaints including
criticisms of the black lives matter
movement which china said was a
sign of america's human rights problems
here at home
the chinese diplomats asked of the tv
cameras to stay in the room to capture
this and the senior biden official later
said this was grandstanding in theatrics
the ambush is just a snapshot of this
conflict to come
this week the secretary of defense vowed
that the u.s is going to keep pace with
china's modernized military which has
been muscle flexing in asia
the secretary of state just the day
before sanctioned 24
chinese officials for human rights
violations in hong kong so
the gloves are off the good news is that
they'll still be talking today
not a good way to kick off the
relationship though margaret thank you